news now special edition
good afternoon and thanks for joining us
here at 4 30. i'm vanessa murphy this is
a special edition of eight news now
we're calling vax facts for kids now
that children as young as five can get
the covid 19 vaccine we want to help
families sort through information right
now just the pfizer vaccine has received
fda approval for kids ages five and up
now joining us in the studio to answer
questions dr routu azuthachin also known
as dr e board certified pediatrician and
joanne rupert chief administrative nurse
at the southern nevada health district
we also have a group of parents joining
us on zoom here because this is a mix of
vaccinated and unvaccinated individuals
here the hope is for this to be a
judgment free zone and to have a
productive discussion now let's start
with dr e can you tell me what you
believe are the benefits and risks of
the covid19 vaccine for children
yes absolutely so i think when we're
talking about the benefits and the risks
of the vaccine we just need to
understand that the landscape for
covid19 has changed significantly in
just a year and a half when we first
started having our lockdown in march
2020 that variant that original coveted
strain was not making children sick the
same way they were they were seeming to
be relatively untouched not getting
hospitalized not dying from it however
this past summer when the delta variant
started we started seeing children get
sick and pediatricians really started
listening and noticing we saw a
five-fold increase in hospitalizations
we've started having children dying from
covid we're seeing increases in
multi-system inflammatory syndrome which
can last for months for some of these
children in terms of side effects so
this vaccine now is effective against
the delta variant and the benefit is it
can prevent hospitalization it can
prevent death it can prevent the
multi-system inflammatory syndrome that
children are experiencing the risks are
the same as any vaccine redness soreness
in the arm fever chills your and that's
really your body saying hey i'm making
an immune response and this vaccine is
working the risk of something really
serious like anaphylaxis shock is the
same with the covet vaccine as it is
with all the other vaccines that your
children are taking
thank you so much now let's go to brian
almero brian you are a dad you told me
you and your wife are vaccinated but
you're on the fence about getting the
vaccine for your child can you tell me
why
so i mean it really comes down to it is
the side effects yeah i mean my wife has
been vaccinated since you know beginning
of the year or middle of the year and
it's the main concern really is i know
she mentions the usual
soreness and and
usual um
the way
the way adults have it is going to be
the same as on the children
it comes down to it is really what more
is it really is that really all the the
side effects or is it more to it i mean
it's been has it been really tested
i mean that's really my concern so so
it's it's kind of like
a war in defense if we're gonna do it
right away or is it better to win
thank you so much and dr e are you
seeing this uh parents like brian who
are on the fence and and what would you
say to them yeah definitely i mean it's
very understandable to to want to know
as much as possible before administering
this for your child and i think what i
would say is in terms of the testing
this vaccine has had over 400 million
doses in the country
and so it's one of the most studied
vaccines we've ever had out there so
that the studies are robust lots of
people have been getting it they're
tracking the safety of it and it's
showing to be more
effective in younger kids and they
actually have less side effects than
older kids and adults
and for
joanne rupert can you talk about are you
seeing this at the health district some
parents like brian being hesitant and
and what would you say to them
well certainly i can understand their uh
their uh concerns about vaccinating
their children uh this vaccine uh you
know has been
rolled out it started last
july and 2020 but the
the research for the mrna the messenger
rna has been going on since 1990 and now
that we're in this pandemic the urgency
really
really forced the
rapid development of the vaccine and we
were able to also receive the
researchers were able to receive funding
for it so uh the government had put a
lot of funding into getting this vaccine
developed and then also tested
thank you so much now up next we'll hear
from more parents both for and against
the covid19 vaccine for children we'll
be right back
welcome back to our vax facts for kids
town hall let's go to mom of two skyler
goodman who says she is not vaccinated
and doesn't plan on getting her children
the covid19 vaccine uh skylar i know you
have some time here your oldest is four
years old
you told me your concern was that you
feel that the approval process was
fast-tracked can you talk about that and
what's your question
yeah so i
definitely feel like there hasn't been
enough time to conduct long-term studies
whether or not there's been
enough money put into conducting these
studies there hasn't been long-term
studies actually put forward so for my
question i would like to ask
according to the american academy of
pediatrics the mortality rate among
children is 0 to
0.03 percent so why should i as a parent
risk my child obtaining any side effect
or adverse reaction to the vaccine like
the many cases already seen among adults
uh dr e can you address skyler's concern
here yeah absolutely so i think one
thing to point out is when you're
looking at mortality rate they're
looking at the collective mortality rate
pre-delta variant as well which we know
is milder which we know had a much lower
mortality rate so
as this continues this pandemic those
numbers may shift the other thing is you
know
how many deaths are okay and do do we
want to risk our own children as part of
that and you know here in clark county
we have had some deaths already and
we've had over 90 cases where children
have had significant serious
consequences with long-term inflammatory
organ damage from it and so in in my
opinion it's kind of like a seat belt
it's not a 100 percent guarantee but i
want that layer of protection for my kid
and and for yours as well
uh skylar hearing that information and
those numbers um does that concern you
and do you feel like you're willing to
take the risk dr e is referring to
yeah i mean
considering the
mortality rate among adults i mean the
survival rate is as well 97 to 99
so to me the risk of my child obtaining
even a side effect but more so
importantly a long-term condition or an
adverse reaction to me
isn't worth them taking the vaccine when
it's not when it's shown that it's not
as effective as it could be when there's
people still getting positive coveted
results and fully vaccinated
uh joanne rue piper the health district
would be aware of something like uh
complications from the vaccine right or
what kind of information does the health
district collect uh
about concerns schuyler is referring to
right well if there is any uh any
adverse event after the vaccine we would
get that information and then all
providers
can also report it to the government
we do know that uh chill that most of
the deaths and hospitalizations that
occur
uh are related to unvaccinated people
for vaccinated people it's a it's a
small percentage
thank you so much now when we come back
we'll hear from a parent who says he's
not an anti-vaxxer but he is against the
covid vaccine he'll tell us why you're
watching a special edition of eight news
now at four
welcome back let's go to mom of two
jacqueline cooper who says she is for
the vaccine jacqueline you told me one
of your concerns is that you feel like
there is resistance to the vaccine in
the community meaning people who are
refusing to get themselves their
families and their children vaccinated
what's your main concern
my main concern is we look at people
in our society and our community and
we're judging them whether or not
they're being safe and that blows my
mind that we're taking something as
simple as humanity and making it such a
a huge
variant in our culture i mean
you look at me you wouldn't know that i
have a sister who has a child at home
with childhood cancer and she can't
leave the house because
of the you know covent and what's going
on and she can't have him get vaccinated
because of his immune system and i have
to protect myself and my surroundings
because i do come in contact with her
and so i'm shamed by other moms and i'm
laughed at for wearing masks in public
but you wouldn't know that unless you
knew my situation and it's frustrating
and it's discouraging and it's
disheartening that people are so selfish
during this time and we have the ability
to build up this great herd immunity and
to to make these great strides to
protect those that are less likely to
overcome this disease and we're
selfishly just ignoring science
blatantly and i just can't get my mind
around it at what point did we stop
trusting the professionals and at what
point did we stop having
compassion for each other and empathy
and that that's what's really on my mind
lately
and thank you jacqueline um
joanne ruper is this something you see
about parents really being polarized
well i i can understand uh jacqueline's
point of view as far as having someone
in their family with cancer and
uh uh you know a compromised immune
system and that is a lot of concern with
those
people who cannot get the vaccine or it
doesn't work as well because of their
immune system so you do have to do a
kind of cocooning around that person to
uh make sure that they don't get sick
and i've you know children sometimes
they also
feel
anxious being out in the world they're
afraid that they might get sick from
covered so maybe having the vaccine
would actually make them feel better and
more confident about getting out and you
know going to activities going to a
friend's house
thank you and jacqueline tell me the
ages of your children
i have a three-year-old and
nine-year-old and what is the status of
the nine-year-old as far as that covid19
vaccine
we just got home on a delayed trip last
night sorry for missing yesterday so we
have not had an opportunity to vaccinate
her yet but we have a appointment
scheduled for this week and she will
have her first dose okay thank you so
much for sharing that with us
we are going to now switch over to
father of six brian dawkins he tells me
he's not an anti-vaxxer but he's against
the covid19 vaccine for himself and his
children uh brian what is your main
concern what's your question
well let me preface my comment first by
saying that i have nothing but respect
for people's decisions regarding masking
social distancing and whether or not
they get the shot i just believe that it
needs to be a personal decision not one
that's coerced
and i do have several areas of concern
but what's most alarming to me is the
fact that congress preemptively
indemnified the pharmaceutical
manufacturers against civil liability
if something goes wrong with the shot
uh they've actually been doing this
since 1988 and another law was passed in
2005 to further protect
the drug makers
and what that does is it doesn't protect
the patients so if i or my wife my
children decide to get the shot
and then have a
adverse reaction
myocarditis or
down the road we find out that they're
all infertile because of something that
happened because of the drug
we have no legal reports we cannot sue
the drug makers and i'm going to i would
recommend joanne ruper of the southern
nevada health district to address that
joanne what would you say about brian's
concern
right so uh
for the you know i would i'm the local
health department and a healthcare
professional so i really can't say
anything about the legal
aspect of it
but
there are a lot of good information on
the cdc website that talks about that
and how that that how did that come
about and how that process
uh
is for those who may uh experience
adverse events thank you so much and
back to brian here uh brian could you do
me a favor and tell me the ages of your
children also a couple of follow-ups
here have any of them contracted the
covid19 vaccine and do any of them want
the vaccine
i'll try to remember your questions in
order
my children are 17 15 15
one's turning 13 tomorrow a 12 year old
and a 9 year old
and no one in my household has
had the virus and no one in my household
has any interest
in getting the shot
and i would rather not wear the masks or
following the protocols although again
we're respectful of other people's
decisions when we're asked to do those
things we comply
but it's not something that anyone in my
household is interested in pursuing
brian are your kids attending school or
what's the situation
my wife and i educate our children at
home but our children are active in the
community
they're involved in several
social organizations and
they have
continued to be around their peers and
adults
for the last year and a half without any
adverse reactions
has any information that you've heard
here so far in this town hall
swayed you one way or the other do you
see yourself ever changing your mind
i'm open-minded i'm willing to change my
mind as facts present that would
encourage me toward that conclusion but
no
nothing that's been said here is any
different than what we've been hearing
the last year and a half
that we should trust the experts and
just go with it and i realized that
adverse side effects from vaccines are
rare but as skyler pointed out earlier
so is death from covid
so we're weighing one slight risk
against another slight risk
and
when we choose to get the shot as i
previously stated there's no legal
recourse while there are injury
compensation programs administered by
the government they have very low
financial tasks that don't measure up to
what a lawsuit would result in and if
something was done incorrectly so no
nothing's been presented that could
change my mind so far okay thank you
brian i want to go back to dr e could
could you weigh in on sort of brian's
view here
well i again i'm on the medical side so
in terms of compensation and sort of the
recourse piece i am i'm no expert in
that but in terms of you know science
and the experts
i understand that this is a global
pandemic and things are continuing to
unfold before us and i love hearing that
he's open-minded because as evidence you
know comes forth and things change and
maybe the landscape changes he might
hear something that speaks to him and i
i believe he would do what he feels is
the best interest of his children which
is ultimately what every parent wants to
do
thank you so much now coming up we'll
see if any parents on our panel change
their minds after this discussion we are
live local now welcome back to our vax
facts for kids town hall i want to turn
back to our parents here on zoom again
this is a mix of vaccinated and
unvaccinated individuals here to listen
to our health care professionals about
the covid19 vaccine you've been
listening in has any of the information
changed your mind if it has changed your
mind because you could you raise your
hand
okay
um now i do want to talk to brian almero
brian i think you're representative of
many parents you told me you're on the
fence could you sort of um tell me what
you thought of the information you heard
here today
well the information given by the two
professionals was very helpful
but as it stands i think i will still be
in the fence because this vaccine for
children under 12 is really so new
to where
uh it's kind of like the same thing for
me and my wife when we waited to get our
vaccine this is really finding out more
information about it uh getting
experiences from other parents uh
because it's it's really a risk i mean
anything is the risk but uh but for my
for our children i mean it's it's much
more important that uh make sure that
they're safe
so i mean my
stance that's still going to be in
defense and really wait a few months
maybe it all depends on how much more
information i could gather and you know
facts and involvement so okay thank you
so much brian dr e what could you say to
wrap this up you know i would share that
again over 400 million doses have been
given in the united states and over 7
billion worldwide highly studied very
safe very effective against covid and
luckily against the the delta variant as
well so you know we have something in
our arsenal to protect our community and
you know i'm encouraging people to
really consider it and talk to their
doctor if they have specific concerns
never forget to do that
and joanne rue piper of the southern
nevada health district i know you said
there's many resources for parents to do
their own research there definitely is i
would really encourage people to do
their research use credible resource
the cdc has good websites
children's hospital of philadelphia
healthy
healthychildren.org all really good
resources with videos and really can
give you a really good visual
thank you so much again thank you to our
parents for joining us we appreciate you
sharing your viewpoints thank you to our
health care professionals in the studio
we hope you had some of your questions
answered during this time as well we
have to wrap it up thank you so much
again for participating our vax facts
for kids town hall